what's happened in China over the last
generation is completely unprecedented
in human history had hundreds of
millions of people literally moved from
agricultural backwardness into into kind
of industrial internet modern industrial
economy and this has generated a vast
amount of wealth and we all know that
China's economy has gone from you know
is growing exponentially but on as this
economic growth has preceded it has also
created a whole series of new problems
which China didn't deal with before the
beginning of the opening reform process
it was one of the most equal countries
in the world now it's one of the most
unequal even more unequal than the
United States of America and you know
700 million people in China a poorer
than the poorest people in Africa and
they live side-by-side with you know
about 30 million people who as rich as
as a developed country and you have
other Chinese in the middle between
those two extremes the destruction of
the Chinese environment is has proceeded
at an absolutely terrifying pace so that
a majority of Chinese people don't have
access to clean water thousands of
people are dying every year from
respiratory diseases because the air is
of such poor quality Chinese farmers
don't have access to enough arable land
in order to to be able to feed the
country so a lot of Westerners worry
about China's impact on the environment
in the future but for Chinese people the
nightmare is already there and then at
the level of social welfare you have
literally hundreds of millions of people
who had some kind of social protection
under the communist system because the
companies they work for gave them you
know a degree of protection if things
were bad having absolutely no safety net
a taller left all on their own and they
terrified of growing old or growing sick
so a lot of Chinese people are starting
to ask difficult questions about where
the economy goes now in the 1980s what
you had was a big division between
the conservatives who wanted to stick
with a command-and-control economy and
the reformers who wanted to embrace the
market but what's happened now is that
the Conservatives have almost died out
nobody wants to go back to the old days
but the reform camp is split in two and
on the one hand you have people who
think that the problem which China has
is that it's only half completed its
economic reforms it needs to go further
and embrace the market even more and
these are the people who very opponents
call them the new right there the
economists who were really influential
in the 80s and 90s and drove the success
of the last 30 years but they say that
you need to finish the job now we need
to privatize the remaining state-owned
enterprises we need to introduce the
market into other areas of society and
that's the way forward and then on the
other hand you've got people who are
very critical that and they say look
look at all the problems which this
embrace of the market has created we
need not to reduce the market into
everything we need to try and develop a
gentler form of capitalism which
delivers for ordinary people and doesn't
see more and more wealth accumulating in
the hands of fewer and for your people
and they're disgusted at the way that
you have a kind of reverse distribution
going on in trying to wear it the the
rich coastal provinces that are growing
at this kind of fast rate of development
are actually being subsidized by the
poorest peasant in inland in the inland
provinces they want to turn that around
and district redistributed money to the
poorest people in Chinese society and
the way that they're thinking about
doing it is partly by learning some of
the most advanced ideas from from the
left in other parts of what is little so
that's quite an important debate and
there has been a I think quite a big
shift in political power within China
because during the 90s when John Ziemann
was president of China and before that
when done shopping was president of
China thus the slogans which were
popular were things like getting rich is
glorious dung Xiaoping said that the
whole of China that China should that
the different states and china should
eat in separate kitchens rather than
from a common pot in other words money
wouldn't be distributed from the from
the poor to the rich and now if you look
at the senior leadership at Preston
in town Prime Minister Wen Jiabao what
they're trying to do is actually to talk
about harmonious society about
scientific development and what they
mean by that is that that more needs to
be done to deliver for many people
because they're seeing that you know
last year there were 87,000 protests a
lot of which were brought about as a
result of the social tensions that are
emerging from from the kind of breakneck
capitalist development in China so there
is a degree of correction which is
coming I've got no idea if it's
sustainable people always predicting the
collapse of China one thing that is
interesting it actually is how resilient
China has been and how its managed to
avoid collapsing at lots of different
stages when people thought it would do
so I remember very clearly going to
China during the Tsar's crisis and
people thought this was going to be a
calamity it was a really big deal but it
barely calls the blip on China's growth
figures for that year so I'm not sure
what will happen in the long term but
certainly if it carries on performing in
the way has done then it will very
quickly I mean it is that is an element
of China's power that for the fact that
it is so successful and that people are
predicting what it's going to turn into
um if the economy does slow down will
that lead to a political opening I mean
it's a one of the things the Chinese
themselves are most obsessed by because
the Communist Party realizes that it's
not going to stay in power because
people believe in mau anymore so
therefore it meal ticket has been the
fact that it has delivered this
incredible economic growth and they
worry about what they'll do if if
economic growth slows and there are lots
of debates within China about how to
deal with it whether it's sensible to
try and have a more balanced model of
economic growth and it's also one of the
things that's leading the government to
try and deal with some of these social
problems because they think if they can
show that their delivery for ordinary
people then that will maybe create a
firmer foundation for their
you